>> Larry: WELCOME BACK TO THE
SHOW!
JOINING OUR PANEL TONIGHT IS
ROLLING STONE JOURNALIST MATT
TAIBBI, FOUNDER AND C.E.O. OF
IRAQ AND AFGHANISTAN VETERANS OF
AMERICA JOURNALIST  PAUL
RIECKHOFF, COMEDIENNE SABRINA
JALEES, AND FORMER SPECIAL OPS
SNIPER AND AUTHOR OF "THE
REAPER," NICK IRVING.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE IT.
IT'S AMAZING A MOVIE LIKE THIS
WILL MAKE $200 MILLION.
WHY DO YOU THINK THAT?
>> IT'S A GREAT MOVIE.
IT'S COMMUNICATING WHAT WE AS
VETERANS HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO
COMMUNICATE FOR A DECADE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PIECES TO
PULL APART BUT AT THE END OF THE
DAY IT'S POWERFUL.
THE VETERANS COMMUNITY IS BEHIND
IT.
IT FEELS AUTHENTIC AND REAL AND
IT'S ENTERTAINING.
THAT HAS AMERICA TALKING.
>> Larry: YOU FEEL IT'S THAT
SIMPLE LEVEL, IT'S JUST THAT WE
WANT TO FEEL GOOD ABOUT IRAQ?
>> AMERICA IS NOT THAT
INTERESTED IN IRAQ OR VETERANS
ISSUES.
WE HAD A V.A. SCANDAL AND NOBODY
GAVE A (BLEEP) BUT NOW EVERYONE
IS FOCUSED.
I'LL TAKE THAT.
WE NEED TO FIND CONNECTIONS AND
THIS FILM DOES THAT.
>> Larry: IF IT GIVES
ATTENTION TO VETERANS THAT'S
GOOD.
>> RIGHT.
>> Larry: WERE YOUR CRITICISMS
THAT YOU FELT THE MOVIE WAS
INACCURATE OR THE PORTRAYAL OF
THE WAR WAS INACCURATE AND IT
MADE A LOT OF MONEY?
>> LOOK, IT DOESN'T HAVE TO BE A
DOCUMENT RI, BUT, I THINK, YOU
KNOW, THE FACT THAT THEY LEFT
OUT THE PART THAT WE INVADED THE
WRONG COUNTRY.
I THINK THAT WAS AN IMPORTANT
PLOT ELEMENT.
>> A TINY LITTLE OMISSION?
YEAH.
LOOK, OBVIOUSLY, IT COMPLETELY
CHANGES THE ENTIRE COMPLEXION OF
THE STORY IF YOU LEAVE OUT THE
CONTEXT OF THE MISSION.
HAT'S ALL I WAS WANTING TO SAY.
I DIDN'T WANT TO DISPARAGE
VETERANS OR THE MILITARY BUT I
FELT LIKE IT LEFT OUT IMPORTANT
HISTORICAL DETAIL.
>> Larry: I KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, BUT TO ME
IT MADE ME FEEL THAT, OKAY,
THAT'S WHAT MADE THAT GUY GO.
NICK, DID YOU THINK IT'S HARD
FOR US TO BE ABLE TO RELATE TO
VETERANS AND PEOPLE WHO ARE
ACTUALLY IN WAR?
>> I DON'T THINK ANYBODY WILL
EVER BE ABLE TO RELATE UNLESS
YOU HAVE BEEN THERE AND SEEN
YOUR BEST FRIEND GET SHOT IN THE
FACE.
I DON'T THINK YOU CAN RELATE TO
THAT.
YOU CAN'T PUT THAT ON CAMERA OR
FILM AND I'VE SEEN IT QUITE
OFTEN.
>> Larry: YOU'RE A SNIPER.
MM-HMM.
>> Larry: YOU HAVE THE MOST
UNRELATABLE -- SNIPER,
PRESIDENT, LATE NIGHT TALK SHOW
HOST --
(LAUGHTER)
-- THOSE ARE THE MOST
UNRELATABLE THINGS.
WHY DO YOU THINK IT IS SO
UNRELATABLE?
>> OUR SKILL SET, OUR JOB IS
HARD TO PUT IN WORDS.
WE'RE SENT OUT THERE TO KILL
PEOPLE.
THAT'S OUR SOLE PURPOSE IN LIFE.
>> Larry: MAN!
NO, BUT WHEN YOU SAY THAT --
>> IT'S HEAVY.
>> Larry: IT IS HEAVY, RIGHT?
I DON'T LOOK AT THE ASPECT
BEHIND IT AS FAR AS, YOU KNOW,
I'M GOING TO KILL THIS GUY.
HE'S NOTHING BUT A TARGET AT
THAT POINT AND IF I CAN PREVENT
ONE OF MY FRIENDS FROM DYING,
RIGHT, I'M GOING TO PUT ONE
THROUGH YOU.
>> Larry: IS IT LOOKING AT HOW
THIS HAS MADE, IN A SENSE?
AS A MOVIE GOER, DO YOU NOT CARE
ABOUT BEING ABLE TO RELATE?
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS COOL TO SHOW
WHAT IT WAS LIKE TO COME HOME
FROM WAR.
THE FEMALE LEAD IN IT WAS KIND
OF ONE DIMENSIONAL.
IT WAS THE SAME THING OVER AND
OVER AGAIN.
LIKE, DON'T GO TO WAR!
DON'T GO TO WAR!
I'M, LIKE, THIS IS THE BEST
SHOOTER IN THE WORLD!
HE'S GOT TO GO TO WAR!
SHE'S LIKE A BROKEN RECORD.
>> Larry: YEAH, I THOUGHT PHIL
WAS SUPPOSED TO DIRECT THE MOVIE
AND IT WOULD HAVE BEEN
DIFFERENT.
>> BUT IT'S CLINT EASTWOOD FILM,
A BLACK AND WHITE VIEW OF THE
WORLD, CHRIS KYLE'S VIEW OF THE
WAR WAS GEORGE BUSH'S AND IT'S
NOT MINE AND NOT EVERYONE
ELSE'S --
>> YOU LIKE THAT PERSPECTIVE.
I LIKE THAT PERSPECTIVE TO BE
TOLD BECAUSE IT'S PART OF THE
LARGER STORY.
IF IT GETS MILLIONS OF PEOPLE TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE'VE GONE
THROUGH, WE'LL TAKE IT.
>> Larry: NICK, HOW MUCH OF AN
ISSUE -- GO AHEAD IF YOU WANT TO
CLAP.
(APPLAUSE)
>> THANK YOU.
>> Larry: HOW MUCH OF AN ISSUE
IS THE PTSD PART OF IT?
>> I THINK IT'S A BIG ISSUE.
MY LAST DEPLOYMENT, IN FOUR
MONTHS, I KILLED 33 GUYS AS A
SNIPER.
>> Larry: 33.
YEAH.
THE BODIES DIDN'T MATTER, I'M
NOT --
>> Larry: YOU'RE NOT ASSESSING
ANY THREATS NOW?
>> NO, I'M A NICE GUY.
(LAUGHTER)
I DON'T HAVE ANY REGRETS ABOUT
KILLING ANYONE.
I REGRET NOT BEING ABLE TO SAVE
THE GUY WHO SAVED MY LIFE.
>> Larry: THAT'S WHAT THEY SAY
IN THE MOVIE.
>> BENJAMIN WAS 21 YEARS OLD,
SAVED MY LIFE AND I WATCHED HIM
TAKE ONE FIVE MINUTES LATER.
>> Larry: DO YOU HAVE TO
COMPARTMENTALIZE THAT?
I WAS TAKEN BY HOW IF YOU DON'T
COMPARTMENTALIZE THAT YOU WILL
BE (BLEEP) ON A MUCH FASTER
ROAD.
BECAUSE PART OF YOU HAS TO BE
MESSED UP ANYWAY -- NOT SAYING
YOU'RE MISSED UP -- BUT YOU HAVE
TO BE KIND OF A DICK.
>> NO, NO, WHEN I GOT OUT, THE
PTSD THING WAS REAL AND WAS
THERE.
I WOULD WAKE UP AT 6:00 A.M. AND
DRINK TILL 4:00 P.M.
I DON'T REMEMBER DRINKING WATER
FOR TWO YEARS, JUST ALCOHOL, TO
TRY TO FORGET.
>> Larry: MATT, DO YOU THINK
THESE MOVIES MAKES IT HARDER OR
EASIER TO KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
GOING THROUGH?
>> IT HELPS.
THE MOVIE CERTAINLY SHOWED HE
HAD A STRUGGLE.
IT WASN'T AS OVERT AS YOU WOULD
HAVE THOUGHT, BUT I THINK IT DID
DEFINITELY ADDRESS SOME OF THAT
IN THE MOVIE.
>> THE COMING HOME PART IS VERY
POWERFUL.
I HAD A LOT OF CIVILIANS SAY TO
ME, NOW I CAN START TOWNS WHAT
YOU WENT THROUGH.
NOBODY EVER ASKS US HOW MANY
PEOPLE WE SAVED.
IT'S NOT THE COMPLETE STORY,
BUTS A VERY COMPLEX THING THAT
HOLLYWOOD WILL NEVER
ENCAPSULATE.
BUT WE'RE HERE ON A COMEDY SHOW
TALKING ABOUT THE WAR AGAIN AND
VETERANS ISSUES AND WE HOPE THAT
DISCUSSION WILL CONTINUE.
>> Larry: DO YOU THINK A
DIFFERENT WAR WOULD HAVE MADE A
LOT OF DIFFERENCE?
PEOPLE HAVE PARTICULAR ISSUES
ABOUT THIS WAR.
IT'S HARD FOR US TO
COMPARTMENTALIZE SOMETIMES.
DO YOU THINK THAT'S A BIG
PROBLEM?
>> MAYBE.
I THINK THE REASON WHY WE WENT
TO IRAQ, I DIDN'T CARE, I SIGNED
UP IN 2004.
>> Larry: WHY DID YOU SIGN UP?
I SAW THE TWIN TOWERS FALL
AND A FEW LAIRTS I WAS IN
AFGHANISTAN, SO I DEPLOYED
MULTIPLE TIMES TO EACH, THREE
TIMES TO IRAQ, TWO TIMES TO
AFGHANISTAN, SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: WELL, DO YOU WANT TO
SAY ONE LAST THING?
>> YEAH, NOW THAT THEY'RE
ALAPPLAUDING, I JUST WANTED TO
ALSO ADD -- NO.
(LAUGHTER)
I THINK YOU GUYS DO AN AMAZING
JOB.
MY FATHER IS PAKISTANI, AND I
GREW UP WITH HIM IN CANADA
LOOKING AT THE TV GOING, OH,
THESE, (BLEEP).
AND MY FATHER IN LAW SERVED OVER
TWO DECADES.
IN GETTING TO KNOW HIM, IT'S NOT
A CARICATURE, THE GUN SLINGERS
VERSUS THE OTHER PEOPLE.
THE MOVIE WAS A LITTLE BIT LIKE
DUCK HUNT BUT INSTEAD OF DUCKS,
IT WAS IRAQIS.
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN?
>> YEAH.
I'M SURE, BEING IN THE WAR,
YOU GUYS MUST HAVE MET TONS OF
PEOPLE THAT WERE NICE THAT
WANTED PEACE.
>> BUT YOU SHOULDN'T GET YOUR
FULL PERSPECTIVE ON IRAQ IN A
TWO-HOUR MOVIE.
READ A BOOK.
COME HANG OUT WITH US.
WE'RE NOT THAT BAD.
>> IF YOU'RE DRINKING AT
6:00 A.M., I WILL HANG OUT WITH
YOU.
>> EXACTLY.
EXACTLY.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Larry: WE MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO AGREE IN THIS MOVIE BUT WE
CAN ALL AGREE DRINKING AT
6:00 A.M. ISN'T ALWAYS A BAD
THING.
OKAY?
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK WITH "KEEP
IT 100"!